hoy en día tenemos dos cerebros el
interno que tenéis dos vosotros y tengo
yo también que está procesando el
sentido de mis palabras analizando si
cada una encaja con la anterior y el
externo por mucho que nos duela es el
smartphone si lo pensamos
casi nadie sale ya de casa sin su
segundo cerebro y es que el smartphone
se ha convertido en una parte esencial
para más de 2.5 billones de personas en
el mundo en menos de 10 años ha cambiado
la forma en la que nos comunicamos nos
relacionamos y consumimos información si
pensamos también en el smartphone nos ha
permitido de alguna manera externalizar
algunos de los cálculos o cómputos
mentales que realizábamos antes nosotros
ya no sé quién calcula la distancia más
corta a casa o se acuerda de los números
de teléfono de sus mejores amigos y esto
es una gran ventaja porque aumenta
nuestras capacidades pero a la vez puede
suponer un gran peligro porque en cierto
modo hay veces en las que nos acomodamos
en estas recetas que nos dan los
algoritmos
nos dejamos puesto el piloto automático
y el cerebro que viene mañana es la
inteligencia artificial la inteligencia
artificial es una área de la computación
que quiere dotar a las máquinas de la
capacidad de pensar y aprender como
nosotros
si pensamos en el impacto en la
inteligencia artificial lo podemos
entender como una receta de ingredientes
en la cocina a que dice el ordenador
cuáles son los pasos que tiene que
seguir esto sería la computación
tradicional la inteligencia artificial
dota a esta cocina de un cocinero que
elige cuáles son las mejores recetas
según los ingredientes y el objetivo
final ahora mismo a través de nuestros
sentidos estáis analizando lo que veis
en lo que sentís y vuestro cerebro en
cierto modo decide si debéis continuar
prestando atención a lo que yo estoy
diciendo o no en esta charla
si entramos a una capa más adentro a una
neurona que tenemos en nuestro cerebro
esta imagen que estamos viendo activa
una dendrita que a su vez transmite
información al núcleo y el núcleo
procesa y decide cuáles son las
siguientes neuronas que se deberían
activar después bueno y qué tiene que
ver todo esto con la inteligencia
artificial pues la realidad es que si
pensamos en una estructura de pocas
neuronas no tiene tanta diferencia se
comportan de un modo muy similar por
ejemplo una red neuronal coge el input
de datos que le pasamos que en este caso
serían imágenes de animales a través de
ese input extrae las características
propias de cada uno de los animales y
decide cuál es la probabilidad que se
ajusta más a los resultados
en este caso como ve que la imagen del
perro tiene características similares a
los que ha visto anteriormente nos dice
que esto tiene la mayor probabilidad de
ser un perro
por ejemplo a mí me gustan muchísimo los
experimentos científicos y a menudo voy
a internet para buscar más vídeos en
algunas de las plataformas que están
disponibles cuando acabo de ver un vídeo
a menudo me muestra tres opciones ver
otro experimento ver la siguiente opción
la siguiente sesión del congreso los
diputados o ver un gato bailando cuál
queréis que elijo cuando llevo puesto el
piloto automático pues efectivamente es
el gato y el problema que hay aquí es
que mi objetivo cuando entro en esa
plataforma que es aprender el máximo
posible no está alineado con el objetivo
de este algoritmo que es que yo me pase
al mayor tiempo posible en la plataforma
para maximizar los ingresos que generó
en ella quizás este sea un caso trivial
en el que pensamos bueno y que quemado
tiene que yo me pasé cinco o diez
minutos más mirando un vídeo de gatitos
bailando en youtube bueno pues hay casos
en los que por la introducción de un
sesgo que básicamente a menudo se
produce por datos incorrectos o la falta
de ellos puede tener implicaciones más
serias pensemos por ejemplo en un barrio
que no recibe visitas porque es ignorado
por culpa de los algoritmos
un currículum que ni siquiera llega a
recursos humanos porque no pasa los
filtros o en el caso extremo un coche
autónomo que no consigue detectarlos a
tiempo y por tanto nosotros vella
en realidad en esencia lo que está
haciendo esta red neuronal es agruparnos
en grupos que tienen las mismas
características con personas similares y
aquí hay un gran problema en las redes
neuronales y es que si un grupo en
particular no está representado no se
verán reflejados sus atributos y
particularidades de cada uno de los
individuos de una manera en que los
algoritmos luego puedan identificar y
esto representa un problema porque estas
personas se vuelven invisibles
invisibles en un mundo en el que cada
vez la inteligencia artificial es más
importante
si pensamos en el sesgo que se produce
esto creo que debería resultar obvio
pero los algoritmos no debían ser
programados únicamente en stanford por
hombres blancos que se acaban de graduar
en la carrera
y es que es esencial que consigamos
incorporar un grupo diverso de perfiles
tanto en género como en edad como en
formación profesional como en región
porque esta es la única manera en la que
vamos a conseguir agrupar cada uno de
los sesgos particulares que traemos
nosotros para disminuir el global que
tiene el algoritmo y de esta manera
hacer más justo el input output que nos
da para todos pero quizás os estaréis
preguntando bueno y qué tiene que ver
esto conmigo no porque en este momento
ni siquiera sé programar pues os quiero
dar una buena noticia y una mala noticia
la mala noticia es que si no sabéis
programar o si no tenéis unas bases unas
nociones de lo que es la programación es
muy difícil casi imposible aprenderlo
que lo que es la inteligencia artificial
y la buena noticia es que como todo se
puede aprender cómo lo sé pues porque yo
en febrero de 2018
ni idea de lo que era una red neuronal y
payton digamos que él entendía más como
una clase de serpiente y no como un
idioma de programación maravilloso
entonces quiero compartir con vosotros
el momento en el que me di cuenta que
realmente esto iba a generar un impacto
que iba a cambiar la forma en que
nosotros interactuamos como sociedad
este cuerpo de forma humanoide que veis
aquí fue creado por deep mind sin
instrucciones sobre en qué consistía
caminar o en cómo se debía desplazar y
el que únicamente se le daba un
incentivo por llegar más lejos se habían
conseguido replicar una de las formas
que nos hace en esencia ser humanos
cuánto faltaría para el resto por
ejemplo un grupo de ingenieros de
stanford consiguió más tarde aumentar la
precisión con la que detectaban el
cáncer de piel con redes convencionales
neuronales con un 72 por ciento de
precisión en frente al 65% que
conseguían los grupos de oftalmólogos
expertos
es cierto que mi proceso de aprendizaje
no ha sido muy convencional en el
momento en el que decidí adentrarme en
la inteligencia artificial fue casi para
enseñar de ello porque pues porque junto
con dos amigos decidimos apuntarnos para
liderar un grupo de estudio sobre la
inteligencia artificial en barcelona es
una comunidad llamada saturdays y
próximamente esperamos poder lanzarlo
también en madrid cuando yo empecé estos
cursos online no acabé ni cuatro de
ellos no conseguía acabarlos y me di
cuenta que el problema no era yo sino
que era la falta de tiempo tomé una
decisión por la que mi padre que está en
esta sala me hecho un par de broncas
pero dejé mi trabajo y decidí aprender a
programar durante el verano más adelante
me admitieron en un máster de
inteligencia artificial que fue una de
las cosas que nunca hubiera querido que
estaba a mi alcance
junto con un grupo de compañeros de ella
y saturdays ahora mismo estamos creando
un proyecto con el objetivo de combinar
las imágenes de los satélites con las
redes convencionales neuronales para
detectar barcos de inmigrantes que están
cruzando el estrecho y así poderles
enviar ayuda en el momento en el que más
la necesitan
[Música]
creo que todavía me queda muchísimo
camino por recorrer pero sí que me
gustaría compartir algunos aprendizajes
que he tenido por el camino por si por
si acaso os decidís adentrarnos en este
campo el primero de ellos es que creo
que nos obligan a tomar una de las
decisiones más importantes de nuestras
vidas cuando no estamos preparados y si
estoy hablando de la lección de la
carrera universitaria y es que es muy
fácil que con 18 años estemos
confundidos incluso nos equivoquemos
pero creo que es una grandísima
oportunidad porque tenemos la
posibilidad de experimentar sin que eso
el trabajo que elegimos a la carrera que
elegimos en ese momento no repercuta a
largo plazo
en el peor de los casos nos podemos
olvidar de ponerlo en el currículum
la segunda de las ventajas que estoy
transmitir es que el contenido que hay
disponible hoy online es de una gran
calidad mejor de lo que muchos de
nosotros podemos acceder a nivel local
tanto si sois autodidactas como si
necesitáis un aprendizaje más guiado
vais a poder acceder a él
pero tampoco si quiero engañar estar
solos delante de un ordenador puede ser
muy frustrante y conllevar a algunos
fracasos esto me lleva a la siguiente
parte y es que intentéis trabajar
siempre en equipo
aparte de porque nos hace más fuertes
vais a conseguir que otras personas nos
motiven a conseguir nuestros objetivos a
la vez que los animales a ellos os va a
permitir especializarnos en un campo
concreto y combinar vuestras habilidades
con las otras personas pero aquí hay
algo más importante además de aprender
de aquellos que saben más tenemos la
obligación de enseñar a aquellos que
saben menos y es que la única manera de
transmitir el conocimiento es ayudar a
otras personas a alcanzar sus metas
[Aplausos]
[Música]
dijo stephen hawking que la inteligencia
artificial puede ser lo mejor o lo peor
que ocurra en toda la historia de la
humanidad
hoy he intentado presentaros el porqué
la inteligencia artificial es una
herramienta que tiene el potencial de
hacer este cambio y sobre todo porque
debemos utilizarla para crear un impacto
positivo e intenta además también
enseñaros porque es un tren que va en
marcha casi sin freno en el que va a
seguir incrementando si pensamos en los
datos no van a disminuir si pensamos en
cómo hacemos nuestro consumo de los
dispositivos y de los dispositivos
móviles y nuestra relaciones van a ir
cada vez más hacia una tendencia digital
que puede ser medida y analizada por
tanto la última pregunta que me queda
por haceros es vais a dejar que un
algoritmo decida por vosotros o vais a
levantarnos y hacer algo al respecto
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]